después de casi 10 horas de viaje
espacial llegaron al que será su hogar
por los próximos seis meses
esta misión china se compone de tres
tripulantes una de ellas la primera
astronauta a entrar en la estación
espacial tiangong
actualmente están configurando algunos
dispositivos de comunicación también
llevarán a cabo varios ajustes por
ejemplo cambios en la nave espacial tras
su acoplamiento le aguaran algunas
adaptaciones que están directamente
relacionados con su vida diaria se
espera que los taikonautas continúen con
la construcción de la primera estación
china y realicen caminatas espaciales
tienen como misión evaluar los sistemas
de soporte vital a bordo de la nave y
monitorear cómo se adaptan sus cuerpos a
largas estancias los paneles solares se
han extendido y funcionan normalmente
anunció que la misión del lanzamiento
del shenzhou 3 es un completo éxito el
lanzamiento hace parte de la búsqueda de
china por tener mayor presencia en el
espacio el gigante asiático fue vetado
de la estación de la nasa en 2011 tras
la sospecha de que había información de
fabricantes satelitales estadounidenses
para desarrollar sus propios misiles en
el futuro china podría convertirse en el
único país en tener presencia en el
espacio tras el posible cierre de la
estación espacial internacional